the creek in the cave and long island
city closed it's where i
really started my comedy career it was a
mexican restaurant did it
serve expired food perhaps
did they know how to melt cheese not
really you'd think that would be a
prerequisite for a mexican restaurant
melting cheese but that's okay it was
about comedy
a lot of great comedians came out of
there not really
but some donald glover went there once
so they just say
donald glover he was like just stopped
in there once
rebecca trent the owner loved comedy
and we appreciate her she allowed
comedians to go in there and
get better at comedy and then the big
brouhaha
happened when the leaders of skanks
podcast my friends louis jay gomez dave
smith big j
okerson booked milo yiannopoulos to
appear on the program
uh last year and the comedy community in
new york threw
a fit and they threw this woman rebecca
trent
under the bus big time now this woman
and i knew her
she had thanksgivings every year and
christmases for people that did not have
the money to fly home to their families
comics that had moved to new york city
or people that just didn't have families
to fly home to she had christmases for
them
she raised money for several comics that
had cancer
she allowed certain comics to like
almost basically
live at the creek in the cave that
didn't have a place to live
and then everybody decided that all of
that
didn't really mean that she wasn't a
nazi
they went right at her they said well
this woman yes she's fed us
and let us stay here and
given us a place to do comedy but a
podcast at her venue
booked a gay conservative troll
so this woman as you know she's a part
of the german bund
i guess i don't know but
it was a split in the comedy community
um between
the comics that were like hey respect
the right of artists to do whatever they
want and the comics that were like she's
a
nazi and i don't like nazis
nazis are bad
so there was that very reasonable
rational discourse
that was had between people that were
like well
we're respecting the right of a podcast
to have on a guest that is controversial
and then on the other side people that
were like are you gonna put
people in gas chambers hitler
you're like well no it was just gonna
let a guy who lost his entire career
appear in the basement of a mexican
restaurant on the legion of skanks
podcast
uh a guy who had lost a book deal when
it lost all his spots on fox news he
would have imagined that
this would be the kind of justice you
people wanted right i mean
he's literally sitting there as they fry
[ __ ] tortillas
and he's got to make a point about
globalism
okay while he he has to step on
guacamole
he's not not saying she's a nazi and
you're a nazi
that's gonna be the musical about this
era nazis here
nazis there nazis everywhere
these people think it's like the sound
of music except in that era there were
actual nazis everywhere now it's like
everybody's like so she never fully
recovered from that her image
in the community not to people like me
we digger
but the looney tunes now the problem is
when you own a comedy venue
many of the people that that go there
are looney tunes
they're maniacal so when you
uh fall on the wrong side of crazy town
those people are angry at you
and that hurts your business because
they
say that you are supporting hate speech
and they had anthony kumia on and people
went nuts about
that
and unfortunately this woman never and
she called me and i spoke to her about
it
and i said listen lewis called me i
remember i was outside of my apartment
at queen's lewis goes
is this guy really that bad is milo that
bad i go i don't really think
it's it's that big of a deal
but i said then again you're asking me
but i i
i don't think it's that big of a deal um
that's me but she called me and she goes
what am i doing am i doing the right
thing here i said i think you
are i don't think it will end with milo
yiannopoulos i think if you
would allow um people to
shut down a controversial guest on a
podcast this doesn't stop
with that guy it just won't
and and she you know
agreed with me and now her business is
closed
and that's it but i think it was it's
the corona lockdown
but part of it is that as a mind virus
that's eating the minds of many people
that you knew
and that you were friends with and uh
biden's win will not
cure them by the way uh it will not cure
them
and you know i feel bad for her because
i think that was this weird turning
point
where the people that she had supported
and the people that
she had also just learn how to melt
cheese
but the people that she had supported
and the and the people that
she had gone to bat for did not really
go to bat for her i did i was on social
media
you know bringing it up saying this
woman all she's done is trying to help
comedians but
what are you gonna do you know